à quelques jours de noël et du jour de
l'an vous savez peut-être déjà quel plat
vous servir et à vos convives oui mais
avec quel vin pour accompagner huîtres
viandes rouges ou blanches la touraine a
tout ce qu'il faut dans ces caves du
chignon vouvray nos conseils pour
réussir vos accompagnement avec aurélie
renault les bulles incontournable stars
de nos fêtes à la cave coopérative de
vouvray mathieu nous conseille le brut
est idéal l'extra brut plus rare est un
peu moins sucré très désaltérant si vous
ne voyez pas d'ag souvent c'est une
cuvée classique une cuvée de réserve on
pourrait dire donc c'est le premier vin
dans la gamme et ça donne normalement un
vin assez léger en goûts avec des bulles
bien présente et rafraîchissant après
quand on arrive déjà un petit peu plus
cher mille les humer vous aurez des
bulles bien plus fine encore un peu plus
fondu dans le vin est un goût à des
arômes crise qui seront plus marquées
quelque chose d'un peu plus vineux
compter entre 9 et 13 euros ici pour de
jolies bouteilles que vous ne passerez
pas au congélateur pour un effet frappé
en effet le grand froid casse le goût du
vin quelques heures au réfrigérateur
suffisent la dégustation se fera dans
une flûte donc un verre fin avec un fond
un petit peu pointu entre lime et du
coup ça va faire un point d'accroché
pour le train bleu pour en savoir plus
sur les accords mets et vins direction
la vinothèque deux tours avec olivier
pour les huîtres le touraine sauvignon
lui semble incontournable on est sur
quelque chose qui est frais on est sur
la jeunesse la fraîcheur le côté un
petit plus acidulée ça c'est vraiment
parfait pour vous comment ces attaques
et sur nos ici on si on souhaite pas
aller pourquoi pas si on ouvre en
muscadet ça ça coûte 7 euros 90 donc ses
rangs une entrée de gamme mais de grande
qualité et surtout avec un grand plaisir
pour énormément de personnes pour une
volaille rôtie olivier optent pour des
cuves est assez souple de saint nicolas
de bourgueil pour une dizaine d'euros
pour une viande rouge ou un plat en
sauce le cabistes par sur chinon sur par
exemple des terroirs de cramant les
coteaux et puis on a encore nous la
chance d'avoir des vieilles vignes sur
des musiques 2015 qui sont des vins qui
sont plaint qu'ils sont entiers qui sont
très bons à boire aujourd'hui je sens et
des bouteilles en 2015 qui sont à 13
euros 90 donc voilà on peut se faire
plaisir pour accompagner des jolis plats
avec des bouteilles de très belle
facture et dans des budgets raisonnables
des vins rouges que vous pourrez mettre
en carafe et que vous garderez à
température ambiante avant de les
partager avec modération